à la ferme de leur meute roues
l'ambiance est très particulière
c'est aujourd'hui que débute la première
récolte des cépages rouges de pinot noir
et de gamme est planté en 2015 au
ramassage
ils sont une dizaine de bénévoles et
employés de chambord à s'activer
certains comme jean pierre attendait ce
moment depuis très longtemps
j'obtiens peut pas re souvenir puisque
mon père avait les mêmes cépages ya il
ya 50 ans sur toutes ces pages
romorantin et puis bon bah pour moi
c'est tout un événement quand même 2
alors que je connais bien le cépage
devenir al komane de chambord pour
couper les raisins pour le responsable
de l'exploitation
la pression est importante car le
domaine de chambord visant vins de haute
qualité prestige oblige donc là vous
arrêter là parce qu'après les plus rien
et vous basculez sur les gars mais la
vendange se fait manuellement puisque
c'est ce que nous avons décidé pour
augmenter la qualité du vin que nous
allons produire
on a assez donné tous les moyens à
chambord de faire une très bon vin c'est
pas dans l'histoire de chambord que de
faire du vin est foutue coup il faut
absolument qu'on ait ce signe distinctif
de qualité
yann saussereau le viticulteur est
plutôt confiant pour cette première
année
hormis une petite inquiétude quant à la
taille des grappes
j'ai pas eu beaucoup d'eau et
par rapport aux collègues qui ont eu par
endroits beaucoup dans le mois de mai
moi j'en ai pas eu beaucoup et du coup
qui m'a permis d'avoir beaucoup de
maladies et puis là mais maintenant oui
ça souffre un peu lâche à leur compte et
grâce n'ont pas pu gonfler c'est resté
tout petit coin dans quelques jours ce
sera au tour du cépage romorantin tant
appréciée de françois 1er d'être
vendanger il faudra ensuite attendre
mars 2019 pour savourer la première
cuvée cuvée qui marquera d'ailleurs les
500 ans de chambord